hip-hop crooner Snoop Doggy puff has a
new piece out on our fearless leader
it's called make America [ __ ] again now
I wanted to play this clip of the random
noises and cacophony that he calls a
musical piece but unfortunately there is
summat so much expletive in it that we
can't do it on the show yeah it'd just
be a bleep it'd just be a long bleep so
I can quote the lyrics Snoop Snoopy says
the president wants to make America
great again eff that we gonna make
America [ __ ] again [ __ ] referring to the
gang that I guess he was associated with
now this is a marked change in hip-hop
hip-hop is turning on president Trump
now but hip-hop used to love Trump
because he was a symbol of conspicuous
wealth and success and something to
aspire to so a young musician named
Young Jeezy once warbled quote and I'm
gonna change a couple words because I
don't want to get yelled at
quote richest ninja in my hood call me
Donald Trump there were 318 mentions
according to Nate Silver at 538 of
Donald Trump between 1989 and 2016 amber
why does hip-hop not like Donald Trump
anymore well because he's a Republican I
mean it's fairly obvious these rappers
are good buddies with Barack Obama and I
guess to some extent Hillary Clinton
although I don't think she's quite hip
enough for most of them but the part
that really got me about Snoop Dogg's
rap is mentioning he wants to make
America [ __ ] again he explained that the
Crips were originally founded to be sort
of the new Black Panther Party obviously
what they ended up being was a very
violent gang in California so for him to
lecture about Donald Trump being a
terrible person and with Eminem - but
enter promote gang culture is a bit
absurd I would think snoops also a
drive-by shooting criminals so you know
I mean it's at least it's of a piece
when he says we want to make pun
intended then he wants to make America
[ __ ] again Beaubois is there anything
redeeming about this terrible music
because I try you know people say I'm
like an old curmudgeon I sound like a
caricature of just an old Republican or
like you kids with your hip-hop but it's
horrible it's just not good I
so frequently tried to convince myself
that hip-hop songs are like are good or
in any way but I can't they're just
terrible
is there anything redeeming about it
well as Aristotle said Michael as
Aristotle said Michael music gives soul
to the universe and to be quite honest
I've always found hip-hop to be a very
miserable genre of music it won its way
to carnal of a genre it just it's all
about just just the beat itself and
that's why if you listen to even like a
quote-unquote good hip hop song you're
pretty much bored with it within like to
two or three days and you never really
want to return to listen to whatever
again so that's one thing but in terms
of the culture that it's bred especially
when you look at previous musician black
musicians of previous generation you had
soul music you had gentlemen like a Nat
King Cole so such a beautiful music that
contributed so wonderfully to the
American Songbook and and there's
nothing that's gonna be remembered in
hip-hop 50 years from now it's just
gonna be considered just like oh yeah a
music genre that came in life but
nobody's gonna be returning to the
classics of Snoop Dogg you know singing
about money on his mind 50 years from
now and and you know the horrible
culture of misogyny that it bread's so I
look forward to its death completely
you're a hopeless optimist rather I
think they probably will be looking back
on these guys and you mentioned the how
carnal the music is it's all about sex
and treating women terribly but you know
you bring up soul music to soul music is
extremely sensual in some ways carnal
but soul music is great there are a lot
of excellent songs in Soul and Motown
that kind of take you on a journey and
they're musically somewhat sophisticated
and lyrically compelling and this stuff
is just garbage
so I even tried I've tried to listen to
Kanye one time because everyone told me
well mostly Kanye just told me he's the
greatest musical genius ever so I
decided to see if he was right and the
thing is he is sort of good in that he
has good taste in music so he samples
good songs and then he makes them worse
by singing on them so like even even
wrote
song with Paul McCartney write a couple
songs one is called only one which is
really good Kim Kardashian said it was
her favorite Kanye song
it's her favorite Kanye song cuz Paul
McCartney wrote it and then he and it
sounds really good except for Kanye's
awful voice but I think that's that's
the trouble maybe they have a good sense
of music but just they don't have any
talent so it produces this garbage and
but we'll have to tie that into maybe
one of Andrew Klavan segments are crappy
culture